the frightening bald Queen on Star Trek
Picard is truly a sight to see so who's
the actress underneath all that makeup
and Prosthetics here's what she really
looks like the Star Trek Picard series
finale titled the last generation
follows a former crew of the USS
Enterprise D in their attempt to save
Picard's son jack Crusher from the
Vengeance of the conniving Borg Queen
though Alice Creek partially reprises
her role from Star Trek first Contact
when the character first appears when
episode prior in season 3 episode 9
another actor actually stood in on set
in full makeup as the iconic Star Trek
villain whereas Krieg is credited with
the ball Queen's voice actor Jane and
wiener Seymour stood in for the
character physically this means that it
was Seymour and not Krieg who took on
the burden of whatever makeup and
costuming requirements were required to
depict the character it's unclear why
Seymour stepped in as krieg's body
double for episode 9 however given that
the actor's face cannot be seen during
her big reveal Seymour notably has
worked steadily since 2010 with her
longest running instant being on the
television series Nova Vita so while
Craig does indeed lend a familiar voice
to the Borg Queen between her
appearances and Vox and the last
generation it's thanks to Jane and
wiener Seymour who physically embodies
her Star Trek villain as she comes to
life on screen while trekkies couldn't
see her face when she first appeared
fans could nevertheless recognize the
distinct voice of franchise veteran
Alice Creek as a ball Queen in her first
Star Trek Picard appearance I I am the
Borg in fact Sharona Terry matalis
alluded to why Krieg may only be voicing
the Borg Queen and not physically
portraying her in the final two episodes
of Star Trek Picard season 3. matalis
said in a collider interview it is Alice
Krieg as the ball Queen you will see in
the finale though it is voiced by Alice
Creek but the bald Queen does not look
good when you see her Janeway did a
number on them the last time we saw them
and there's a reason she needs Jack
Janeway and the Queen's running join a
series finale of Star Trek Voyager does
indeed leave the Borg badly damaged so
that may play into Jane and Weiner
Seymour's presence on set leaving
Seymour the work of physically embodying
the damaged character perhaps Seymour's
most familiar role to picardo viewers is
an appearance in the season 3 premiere
of the Netflix drama you in which she
simply credited a slightly older Punk
lady fans curious to see what the bored
Queen looks like underneath her makeup
you can check out this episode to catch
a glimpse of the Star Trek aliens hidden
Human Side according to Jane Edwina
Seymour's personal website following her
appearances as the board Queen in the
final two episodes of Star Trek Picard
she'll be appearing in the upcoming Star
Wars series Ahsoka precisely how she'll
factor into the show has yet to be
detailed but she refers to the role as
recurring on her website of course given
the genre is entirely possible that
she'll once again portray a heavily made
up alien character while her career
trajectory May currently require makeup
and costume heavy acting work many of
Seymour's roles prior to Star Trek are
as regular human beings for instance she
plays a therapist in the Amazon Prime
video drama hand of God with prominent
roles in both Star Trek and Star Wars to
finding this current chapter of her
career it's entirely possible that
Seymour May soon be playing monstrous
villains on screen in the near future